there's been a little bit of a well they
won't they with the Babylon 5
live-action reboot well now it's not
just looking like they will
but it's looking like there's quite a
few companies that are more than happy
to pay for it welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
thank you
the animated movie The Road home has
done very well thank you very much
apparently sales have been at the top
end of the sort of predicted
expectations and that has made Warner
Brothers very happy it's also made them
far more confident that yes they would
like to go ahead with the Babylon 5 live
action reboot the J Michael suzinski has
been talking about for nearly two years
now so just as a quick recap in case you
don't know J Michael zaczynski about 18
months ago two years ago now started
talking about on Twitter as he does a
possibility for a boots up complete hard
reboot of the Babylon 5 franchise
apparently this was going to be on the
CW at the time the guy that ran the CW
is a big fan and was desperate to get
Babylon 5 back he though that guy I
think his name is perowitz is now out of
a job as the CW is owned by next star
next star like Golf and reality TV stuff
that's cheap to make and people watch I
don't know why so I've reported a couple
of times now that the CW were no longer
really interested in Babylon 5.
initially they put it on pause but the
year just gone they basically announced
that we've picked up these shows and if
you're not on the list you're not coming
in but Warner Brothers were not too
concerned they had put Babylon 5 on HBO
Bo or Max or whatever the hell it's
called this week and it had done very
well they have those numbers to show how
well it had done this was all part of a
bigger plan because they knew the
animated movie was coming so they wanted
to Stew up a little Babylon 5 interest
and that plan did very well so now it's
time for the next phase of that plan for
Babylon 5 the complete live action
reboot to get made and to get sold to a
new streaming provider now I've been
able to tell you exclusively and first
here on Sidetrack as I always do but
actually Apple were very interested in
the possibility of this Babylon 5 reboot
now apparently that interest is still
there but Warner Brothers are not 100
certain how serious that interest is
there is a feeling within Warner
Brothers and a couple of people that
I've spoken to that basically Apple will
express interest in anything and
everything that they are more than happy
to of those conversations but then when
it actually comes down to putting a name
on a signature on an actual contract
they drag their heels so they're not 100
certain over at Warner Brothers if
Apple's interest is actually genuine and
they're actually serious about it or if
it's just doing what they normally do
and basically not saying no to anything
apparently though the CW who had said no
to Babylon 5 have maybe after seeing how
well the DVD sales have done have now
expressed another interest in the
possibility of actually taking the
franchise back but again Warner Brothers
don't really believe this interest is
serious they also don't believe that the
budget the amount of money they're
willing to pay for it is serious and
actually even though the CW did have
contractually first dibs on Babylon 5.
Warner Brothers believe that those first
divs have been let go already and that
contractually actually if Babylon 5 is
owned solely by Warner Brothers so they
really can do what they want even though
there is this I say first dibs contract
that actually Warner Brothers no longer
believe there is any reason to even
discuss this with the CW and actually
from a legal point of view CW have
already let go of those rights so that
as it currently stands even though the
CW have expressed maybe a very tentative
interest and expressed maybe a very
tentative budget
Warner Brothers still are looking for
someone else to take on the show because
at the end of the day Warner Brothers
want to make this but they want to make
it to a profit they do not want any risk
from Babylon 5 at all Warner Brothers
cannot afford to lose any more money on
anything so they are looking for a
partner to come in to give them hard
cash for the show and then to just make
it and let it free into the world
they do not want any risk and they do
feel that the CW proposal is
risky they have of course asked Netflix
knocked on the door excuse me Netflix
can we have some of your money and
Netflix have gone now apparently Netflix
have shown zero interest in Babylon 5
there was a very brief discussion
apparently two or three months ago and
that conversation didn't get very far
Netflix really are focusing on producing
other types of content and they don't
see that Babylon 5 really is their kind
of thing there is however a very serious
interest from Amazon now Amazon have got
a really good working relationship with
Warner Brothers at the moment they
basically exclusively sold the DVD the
road home and from Warner Brothers and
they've also got a very good deals with
Warner Brothers animation they're doing
a couple of projects we want Bridges at
the moment they have done several
projects through MGM with Warner
Brothers Amazon and Warner Brothers get
on very well
so those conversations apparently have
happened that Warner Brothers have said
look we've got Babylon 5. you've just
sold it on your platform it's done very
well we put it on Max it did very well
would you be interested in a hard reboot
now apparently Amazon have held several
conversations now about this with Warner
Brothers this has not just been a
one-time thing this has been something
that's been talked about apparently for
nearly 12 months that potentially if
Warner Brothers were to produce it that
Amazon would buy it however at Amazon
there are two schools of thought
one would be to actually give this a
really healthy budget and put it on
Prime and to really see if they could
produce a high concept Sci-Fi show
something that really would be very high
in special effects Etc and would have a
really decent budget
however Amazon have apparently leaned
away from that idea they believe that
one of the things that was really most
beloved and most important and core to
Babylon 5 is whether it wasn't a big
expensive show that it was always kind
of done a bit of a budget
it was always seen as the poor man Star
Trek and they really want to carry on
that feel through into the new show they
want to sort of do something that
wouldn't necessarily have a big budget
and really have a feel of sort of the
scrappy Underdog in the Sci-Fi genre
for that they think 3v is actually the
best place to put the new show they're
looking for new content all the time for
freebie but let's be honest if that's
where the show ends up it won't have the
budget that it would if it ended up on
prime it would be a much smaller budget
and I'm not 100 convinced that's not a
bad thing one thing JMS was good at when
he did the original series of Babylon 5
was do this show with a limited budget
it was Poor Man Star Trek and that's one
of the reasons why we loved it
he was forced to think up creative ways
of making the dollar get on the screen
most effectively he couldn't have big
name actors he instead had to find good
actors good strong character actors that
were just bloody good at what they did
rather than being just a name you know
and I actually do wonder if that might
give us a product at the end that still
feels a bit like the original Babylon 5.
so that is where we stand from right now
Warner Brothers are continuing to have
conversations with other streaming
providers at the end of the day until
the strikes are done they're not going
to be making any final decisions on this
anyway but it is good to know that the
conversations are still happening as I
said apple is still in the game they are
still tentatively interested Netflix
nada
CW possibly have had their heads turned
by the success of the DVD sales but
Amazon are the ones that seem to be
actually ready to Fork up for cash and
actually seem to be the only ones with a
real serious proposal for Warner
Brothers and also there's still the
possibility that Warner Brothers could
just make it for themselves and stick it
on Max but in all honesty I don't think
that was ever a possibility so guys game
for comments tell me what you think is
this idea of a smaller budget TV show
for Babylon 5 and putting it on 3v
something that would appeal to you
because at the end of the day it's not
behind a paywall and would it feel more
like the original Babylon 5 if it didn't
have the big massive budget I think so
but what do you think get into the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution that really supports the
channel you get to see them throughout
the adverts also check out our new
website at
sidetrack.co.uk where you'll see lots of
in-depth stories about everything we
cover on the channel the Articles will
go out roughly the same day as the
videos and should hopefully give you a
little bit more to chew on please go and
check out the website
as always please stay safe guys and I'll
see you next time
[Music]